le nouveau président américain arrive
dans un contexte de relation fortement
dégradée entre la russie et les etats
unis les autorités russes estiment avoir
fait le premier pas dans plusieurs
domaines sans avoir reçu de retours
positifs de washington exemple récent
la proposition de prolonger d'un an sans
condition le traité new start de
réduction des armes stratégiques qui
arrive à échéance le 5 février prochain
une proposition laisser lettre morte
résultat dorénavant moscou ne prendra
plus l'initiative et attendra une
réaction de la part des américains
je ne vous dis rien de nouveau ici car
la russie a entrepris maintes démarches
initiatives et propositions auprès de
ses partenaires américains pour
intensifier les échanges et la
coopération
les contacts dans divers domaines au
four lavish d'akabo oscars est le moteur
institute navire lensois
il s'agit donc plutôt du fait que nous
devrons attendre de nos collègues
américains des réponses à tout ce qui
est déjà sur la table des négociations à
ce qui a déjà été proposé et les passes
d'armes entre les deux pays peuvent
prendre des formes très concrète avec
notamment les sanctions américaines
contre le projet de gazoduc russo
allemand north stream de la porte parole
de la diplomatie russe
ces sanctions ne font qu'aggraver les
relations entre les états unis et la
russie
ce qui est étonnant c'est la
détermination obstiné des autorités
américaines d'empêcher coûte que coûte
l'achèvement de ce projet
les menaces de recourir à des
initiatives discriminatoire suscite
depuis longtemps l'indignation non
seulement en russie mais aussi dans les
milieux officiels et d'affaires de la
plupart des capitales européennes
notamment de berlin de paris devienne
partout on a posé et continuent de poser
la question de savoir pourquoi la
politique énergétique européenne devait
être dirigée par washington et mise en
oeuvre sur le continent européen
par exemple par l'intermédiaire des
ambassadeurs des etats-unis dans ces
pays et il est sur ce dossier la russie
peut compter sur la chancelière
allemande qui a renouvelé aujourd'hui
son soutien au chantier du gazoduc est
terminé
à près de 95 % ce qui a de quoi déplaire
à washington qui estime de son côté que
ce projet menace la sécurité énergétique
de l'europe
pour conclure la diplomatie russe dit
espérer une politique plus réfléchie
dans la part de leur partenaire
américain
même si dans les faits elle ne se fait
pas trop d'illusions